à ce jour la microbrasserie le
naufrageur a créé une trentaine de
bières blondes rousses en bray blanche
noire
l'ardoisé est bien garni la dernière en
lice une bière salines la cause sur mer
d'inspiration allemande les ingrédients
orge blé houblon et de l'eau de mer qui
représente 18% du liquide des culs de
brassage un ami pêcheur pêcheurs de
homard de carmaux tonnes qui nous a
sortis en mer on le pomper environ 3 km
duke et on est allé à peu près 3 km du
quai on a pompé notre eau un endroit où
on savait que l'eau était belle et le
plus pur possible
résultat une bière blonde estivale et
douce se dit on plus faible en alcool à
4,2 pour cent et selon le brasseur boire
cette bière serait une expérience
sensorielle on retrouve vraiment même
aunis quelque chose d'un peu marin à la
bouche ça te lèves les salesses les la
bouche un peu salée comme quand ils
baignent la gauche sur mer est brassée
en petites quantités 7000 litres environ
et des bières éphémère l'entreprise veut
en produire aux deux semaines cette
année pour souligner ses 10 ans ouais le
marché recherche beaucoup de nouveautés
en fait ça c'est un fait
recherchent des produits
qui est qui qui ont un effet wow c'est
en veut qui donc voici une nouvelle
bière saline pour les amateurs de
houblon de bière à découvrir fait à
partir de l'eau salée de la baie des
chaleurs
une bière qui sera lancée dans une
semaine ici puis à cotton radio-canada à
carleton sur mer